nos dicen identifica las unidades más
razonables para medir cada una de las
opciones de bajo cada opción debe estar
situada en una categoría y bueno tengo
dos mililitros litros y kilos litros y
lo primero que me dicen es el volumen de
una piscina de tamaño olímpico y bueno
si sacáramos a todo su volumen en litros
o en mililitros creo que no sería la
opción correcta me parece mejor los
kilos litros
me parece una unidad bastante razonable
para medir el volumen de una piscina de
tamaño olímpico así que la voy a poner
aquí después me dicen el volumen de una
dosis de jarabe para la tos bueno no te
vas a tomar un litro de jarabe para la
tos por lo tanto creo que la mejor
opción en este caso son los mililitros 2
mililitros nos van a servir para ver qué
volumen de una dosis de jarabe de la tos
nos vamos a tomar y bueno por último
tengo el volumen del fregadero de una
cocina y eso creo que lo podemos medir
bastante bien en litros
así que si yo ocupo los litros para
tomar el volumen del fregadero de una
cocina ya tengo aquí mis tres unidades
asociadas a cada uno de estos tres
volúmenes por lo tanto es hora de
comprobar respuesta y perfecto estamos
bien así que vamos a hacer algunos
ejercicios más para seguir trabajando
con las unidades correctas vamos a ver
el siguiente ejercicio bien ahora
tenemos otras dos opciones libras y
onzas y lo quiero asociar con el peso de
una barra de caramelo promedio o el peso
de un adulto promedio y bueno una libra
es cercano a medio kilogramo y una onza
es cercano a 30 gramos por lo tanto el
peso de una barra de caramelo promedio
creo que sería muy bueno metido en onzas
lo voy a medir en onzas porque si lo
mido en libras sería una barra de
caramelo un poco grande no crees y
entonces las libras que son como medio
kilogramo y las voy a ocupar para medir
el peso de un adulto promedio por lo
tanto las voy a poner aquí de hecho el
peso de un adulto muchas veces se mide
en libras
vamos a comprobar mi respuesta otra vez
y de lujo estamos bien así que vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio más identifica las
unidades más razonables para medir el
volumen de cada una de las opciones de
bajo y bueno aquí tengo que los puedo
medir en litros en mililitros y en kilo
litros y bueno claro como sabemos un
kilo litro son 1000 litros y un
mililitro es lo mismo que una milésima
parte de un litro o pensado de otra
manera un litro es lo mismo que mil
mililitros y un kilo litro es lo mismo
que mil litros ok vamos a ver qué nos
dicen estas opciones una cucharada llena
de leche ok en dado caso de que no fuera
una cucharada enorme gigante entonces
creo que una cucharada llena de leche lo
podemos medir en mililitros de lujo el
tanque de un camión cisterna el tanque
de un camión cisterna imagínate la
cantidad de litros imagínate la cantidad
de volumen que tiene este camión por lo
tanto
tal vez podríamos medir en litros en
mililitros en definitiva no pero creo
que los kilos litros son bastante
razonables para utilizar el tanque de un
camión cisterna así que lo voy a poner
por acá una taza de jugo ok una taza de
jugo bueno a menos que sea un litro de
jugo casi siempre las tasas son más
pequeñas y esto se mide en mililitros el
tanque de gasolina de un automóvil bueno
ese sí sabemos que se mide en litros
cuando uno va a llenar el tanque de
gasolina de su automóvil nos podemos
fijar cuántos litros tiene este tanque
de gasolina y bueno para finalizar
déjeme bajar un poco la pantalla
tengo una piscina de tamaño medio una
piscina de tamaño medio
bueno en mililitros no sería la mejor
opción en litros y no sería la mejor
opción porque creo que el volumen de una
piscina de tamaño medio es mucho más
fácil medirla en kilo litros es decir en
una unidad que sea
y ya está ya tengo a todas y cada una de
estas opciones divididas en estas tres
categorías y entonces es hora de
comprobar respuesta así que veamos de
lujo estamos bien hasta el siguiente
vídeo